i was inspired by the matrix the matrix
changed my life
to get to be here again it's really
pretty incredible
it's such an iconic bot of cinema of
entertainment
this is not a retelling this is a new
town
being a part of this film
with the performances the writing the
ambition the scale the scope the thought
provocation
it's been now taken to another level
[Music]
in terms of the matrix world we're back
inside
we come to learn that thomas had a
nervous breakdown in the past
he's having these episodes feeling like
he's in a different world than he's
actually in
[Music]
i have an analyst in the film
he has me taking blue pills to help me
and at the same time thomas anderson
meets this character tiffany who we
would recognize as
trinity
have we met
tiffany is a mother and a wife and
has a love for motorcycles and through
her conversations with thomas anderson
she senses that something isn't quite
right with her life i began to wonder if
i imagined you
[Music]
this is his apartment
there is this group of people who still
believe that neo was out there and still
believe there's unanswered questions to
get to the bottom of
bugs is a true believer she thinks that
neo is still alive so she has this sort
of rag tag crew with her and they're
just off in search of him time to fly
i'm really really excited about
introducing this new matrix to the world
i think people will like the directional
change that lana's taking she's not just
tried to make the original film again
everything that's come before this
present it's been synthesized and
practiced in a way that you have to be a
master filmmaker to make a film like
this
period
[Music]
[Music]
you